what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money
time well while she's trying to get rich
russell's just trying to get her lunch
money right
i'm here with pelina she's awesome
everybody knows that already
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block by has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto
on their crypto exchange you can deposit
crypto and earn up to eight point six
percent apy in an interest-bearing
account
or you can deposit crypto and take out a
us dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
i'm an investor in the business i sit on
the board i'm a happy customer and you
will be too if you sign up for an
account at blockfy.com
five.com pomp go do it what's up not too
much
you know i was i was yesterday i looked
at an old
lunch money episode and i was like so
nervous to talk
and stuff like that and i'm like bring
it on what does that have to do with the
news oh i don't know
just saying talking to my friends okay
cause you don't have any ones in real
life
[Laughter]
too easy go ahead if you throw a if you
throw me a softball might hit a home run
go who's your best friend
uh the dog
okay we don't have a dog he has a dog um
the u.s just added 245
000 jobs in november but that's not good
news that means it hit a wall
because it was 2024
224 000 fewer than economists had
expected aka 50
less than they had expected i love how
everyone wants to use numbers like we're
not just going to say what it is
it's 50 less than what they expected
yeah that's not good for the
growth of the economy and the jobs
and the recovery so hiring in the us
is now so slow it could take another 40
months for the
job market to fully recover from the
pandemic you know what's going to happen
in 40 months
who knows what's going to happen in 40
40 months no
it can't say it's going to take 40
months it's going to take that's what
they're claiming it's going to take way
longer than that
short term because we have idiots
running our cities who literally just
keep
shutting everything down remember that
mayor of l.a
banned walking outside really that's how
stupid people are you can't walk outside
no here's a great idea open up the
businesses
and if you're old or you've pre-existing
conditions stay inside
that's the answer everyone else it's
99.9
likely that you'll be okay let
the young people go out let the people
without pre-existing
go out live their lives get the economy
running
we don't have to have this black and
white black and white world where either
we shut everything down or we open
everything up
we actually can have nuance in the world
it's an amazing idea
but we can have a world where the
healthy people
and the young people go out and live
their life and create
and produce and do the things that
they're supposed to be doing to make a
living
but if you're old or you've pre-existing
conditions or you're just scared you
even if you're fine
and you're just scared stay inside we
can create programs we can help you we
can protect you
but it doesn't need to be 330 million
americans all have to do the same thing
that's not how a world works is how an
economy works
although i will say after this there is
going to be a lot of internet businesses
started
of course there's been a 40 increase in
company
uh creation being filed for new
companies why
it's because people need to make a
living you literally are keeping you're
preventing people from making a living
and it's unconstitutional and courts are
starting to decide that
that's all go ahead i'm pretty chill
today
people get upset when you don't wear
your black t-shirt
oh he gonna take it off don't
take it off okay that's for you people
those are my friends everly well the
at-home medical testing company founded
by
julia cheek sorry i just really like her
it's one of the few companies that has
experienced growth during the covet
pandemic
it on thursday everly well announced
another triumph
a 175 million dollar series d
round which brings the company's total
capital to more than 250 million
and it gives it a valuation of 1.3
billion dollars
unicorn club okay tell the people
i'm a huge fan obviously we invested
very early
and this has grown incredibly fast and
it's all because of julia
julia is a savage can we just reflect on
that
for a second facts she's one of the best
it's not the best ceos out there
she's probably one of the best founders
i've ever invested founders and ceos
right well usually the founder well not
always true
next go to everlywell.com and go get
your at-home diagnostic test yeah you
can do
food sensitivity there's i think they
have std testing
i think they have i don't know but they
have a clean
we have a clean audience all right so
the world has been inching toward fully
and
autonomous not anonymous fully
autonomous cars for years
in china one company just got even
closer to making it a reality
on thursday auto x an alibaba backed
startup announced it had rolled out
fully driverless robo taxis on public
roads and shenzhen
how many of them 25.
so yes they have cars on the street but
there's 25 of them
hundreds of thousands or millions that
are driving everything no again
look at it look you have to start
somewhere i hear you uh
we know this is gonna happen it's just a
matter of who gets there first
and how long it takes but what i think
is even more interesting
than just is there gonna be autonomous
cars not that's absolutely gonna happen
right it's how do cities change like
imagine if all of a sudden
cities start to retrofit themselves with
sensors on the sides of the roads
to help the cars right so basically the
more information you give the car the
more accurate like the crosswalk like
when somebody's walking there's like
sensors
or what happens if all of a sudden we
now don't need
five lanes of traffic or four lanes of
traffic because the cars are actually
smarter than the humans and don't drive
like idiots
and therefore we only need two lanes of
traffic and we can make the sideways
much longer
uh yeah the side walks much wider and
then we can do things like sideways much
longer i see what your brain did there
was funny
it was funny it didn't work uh and then
we can make the cities more walkable
right encourage more physical activity
outside like there's all kinds of things
that can start to change
when the cars drive themselves and there
you remove a lot of the erratic behavior
and also things like these well also
things like
if you've ever studied how traffic
happens it's fascinating
because what basically occurs is it's
like a wave pattern
so even though like yes there's an
accident sometimes like it blocks the
road okay that's one thing
but usually what will happen is
something happens it's on the side of
the road and some group of people will
slow down
to look and then they speed back up but
when they slow down
then a group behind them has to slow
down and then the group behind them
and people kind of move in these units
in traffic and so when you just stop
doing that and you say hey the car is
going to keep a constant speed
regardless
you actually remove a bunch of traffic
as well can i ask a question
sure so you know how all these like
driverless cars you
when there's videos of them you see the
car there's no driver
but like the wheels turning if it's a
computer doing it why do they gotta make
the wheel turn just
embed it in the technology and have it
go
so pulling uh the way that a car i know
that but you don't
is the steering wheel actually is
connected
if i was to build an autonomous car
there wouldn't be no steering wheel
because obviously there's not a human
there
so i would just embed it in the with all
of these computer vision and you don't
know
so what you're talking about is like
going to be the third fourth fifth
iteration of this
in the future and live in the future
no because what they're doing is they're
retrofitting cars
with autonomous so why don't they just
build a new car
but they actually fit old cars because
it's really expensive to do that and
it's really
difficult to do it so the shortest path
is to simply put all the lidar sensors
and
everything on an existing car and then
just turn the wheel you know what i have
to say to that
what
we can just print more money it's not
that expensive okay
you like that i i like that we're not
going to turn this into every time
we should do this show live um okay
more than 400 lawmakers from 34
different countries
have signed a letter to amazon.com boss
jeff bezos
backing a campaign that claims the tech
giant has dodged admit
and dismissed debts to workers societies
and the planet
they want them to pay the make amazon
pay campaign
was launched on november 27th on black
friday by a coalition of
over 50 organizations with demands
including improvements to working
conditions and full tax transparency
you know what this was what this was an
intelligence test and if you signed it
you're an idiot
that's that's what this was i don't know
if that's what that no that's what this
was
just so we're clear jeff bezos
has created more millionaires than
probably
almost any other company how many
i forget the number 100 right that's
first second of all during the pandemic
jeff bezos hired over a hundred
thousand people he was creating jobs
during the pandemic when everyone else
was firing their employees
and forcing them onto the state in terms
of unemployment benefits etc
jeff bezos was creating jobs he pressed
the gas
and so you can have a lot of things
to complain about in terms of jeff bezos
is rich
but jeff bezos has created a lot of
value in the world he's actually made a
lot of other people
really really rich he's given a lot of
people jobs i think they employ almost a
million people at this point
and here's the craziest part everyone
yells and screams
he paid no taxes well dummies the way
that taxes work
is that you pay taxes on profits and the
reason why he pays so little tax
is because for years he took all the
money
and he reinvested it which meant more
jobs
more innovation more value created and
so yes
he didn't pay taxes because he didn't
make any money
he literally reinvested the money
so that he could continue to grow it and
i get that people
some reason it's become cool to hate
capitalism
but there's no better system and they're
particularly speaking there is no
there is no better system and if you
think that there's a better system
then go move to those systems but the
united states is the most prosperous
safe country in the world it is
literally
there's no better time in history to be
alive
yeah okay i have a good documentary
for you guys for this weekend it's
called the donut
king it's good donut is about d-o-n-u-t
sometimes i'd spell it a different way
oh you're british d-o-u-g-h and ut
oh is that how the british do it yeah
the donut
guys the donut he has a weird like
harvard accent sometimes i'm a harvard
man
see like that's not a i don't even know
what i like to drink martinis in my
smoker's jacket it's like a jamaican
british combo i'm a hobbit okay
so nasa nasa will pay an amazingly low
price
one dollar to have a company make a
single small collection of moon dirt
on the agency's behalf there's a startup
called lunar outpost
bid one dollar and one a nasa contract
to complete a mission under the agency
agency's low-cost lunar resource
collection program
announced earlier this year they want
somebody to go collect samples from the
moon so i read this story and i was like
wow that's so interesting
and then i read another story from today
that said
china spacecraft is returning to earth
with moon samples in a first for the
country
can't the china people just give it to
the nasa people
why would they do that for a dollar
no why i don't know because we're all
working together we all humans
we all the same species same race you
ever heard of the space race
yeah countries are very interesting they
all like to be friends but they carry a
knife in their back pocket in case they
need to stab each other in the back
people are so dumb
we're all humans imagine the aliens came
in attacked or would we be like i'm not
giving you my moon samples because
you're a different country and i don't
think so we'd all band together
against the aliens although you'd make
alien friends how would they be my
friend
what up what up okay squiggly green boy
one time he named him steve which was a
weird yeah steve the alien i go grab a
beer
all right next all right it's lunch
money time
all right hold on a second wait is 12 is
state 12 for
wow i have a lot of them question to you
both
from vish i like your newsletters do you
guys keep track of any user engagement
metrics for your newsletters and how did
you scale up your subscriptions
we both use subseq subseq has great
metrics
they're okay some people look at the
metrics more than others
yeah i look at them so much i actually
plugged my site into
google analytics so i look at those
metrics for
engagement opens what people are reading
all that kind of stuff
the one thing that's interesting about
uh looking at
metrics for content is that a lot of
time people
tell you that they like a cert to read a
certain thing or whatever and then you
look at the data they're actually
reading something
totally different so that's that's good
that's a very good answer i don't really
look at the data that much i only just
checked the little chart to see that
it's going up into the right and if that
if that's happening then i'm cool okay
planet is much smarter
than me about that stuff and so she's
always like looking at how many people
are on the site where they come from
what device are they men are they women
also
it's like okay
brooks asks hey y'all hey brooks
i have only recently started tuning in
tuning into your podcast
for a new listener what episodes of your
podcast you absolutely recommend
everyone should watch i did one with my
wife
that's what i was gonna say oh it's
amazing it's so awesome
we talk about how we met and how i
knocked down a chair
yeah uh i think that what i would do is
i would watch the
most popular ones uh if you just go to
the home page
or like to the channel page on youtube i
think that there's one of the
kind of sections shows you so it's like
chamoth
rao pow a couple of others are all
just look at it by views and obviously
they're popular because they're good
jacques or jack asks
could you take one question for your
next episode and give us a rundown
of your day hour by hour the moment you
wake up
so it's never really the same but he
wakes up like two hours earlier than me
at seven and i sometimes wake up at
night although today i couldn't sleep so
like
anyway so so then so he gets up he goes
to starbucks gets
coffee and a croissant which is really
nice and then i don't get a croissant
i i wake up and i eat the coffee i
basically work for a seamless
like without getting paid from seamless
i walk my ass downstairs and i go and i
get
starbucks for polina the guys downstairs
uh who work in our building and then uh
myself and i bring it back and i'm like
handing it out like i'm the kool-aid man
to everybody
yeah and then what do we do and then we
record lunch money around 10. no we
write
oh you write yes i do email i write i do
calls
i get a lot done in the two hours that
then is sleeping so then i wake up
then we do lunch money then what do we
do
what do you do well i work on the
profile pretty much all day
true we have very different schedules
actually yeah
is very uh introverted in her work
meaning that it's like her and her
computer and she's just
talking to people and she just writes
and reads and does a lot of stuff
me i'm the exact opposite i basically
from the second i start doing calls and
meetings
i do them back to back pretty much all
day uh for like hours and hours
uh and then i block out two or three
days a week uh in the afternoons and i
record podcasts so
right now i'm in the process i'm
recording 30 podcasts in about two weeks
uh so that i don't have to do them over
the holidays and we solve content
and somewhere in between of all that we
try to go work out
um well i do and then
two habits that are really good that
we've started um
during the pandemic is we take a walk
pretty much every day
outside and then we also eat dinner
at the dinner table together which is a
great thing to do
yeah but we always did that i know but i
just think it's good
i gotta eat my dominoes somewhere all
right guys that's it
final one okay so there's this i don't
know who you are but you always ask
great questions and you're really nice
a b c d e f g h i j is the user
seriously the nicest human come on what
is a really good question you guys wish
somebody would ask you
mine would be how is your tomato plant
doing because nobody asked me and it's
literally thriving there's one little
tomato that's almost
red i wish somebody would ask me
can you guys shut up already
these are not good answers to then i
could be quiet all right all right guys
that's
it we'll see you on monday bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends